so hi Ernie thanks for agreeing to air
take part in this M is buff their film
session and Acland and we've got some
questions here fire yeah first question
is regarding all of the research and
physical preparation that you did for
the theory of everything with it not
being filmed chronologically how did you
find going between different stages of
the disease obviously movement and
explosion what's interesting about film
I find in relation to theater is there
is no there is no blueprint but no one
tells you how to go about it or to
approach it and so it's only through
learning from mistakes or speaking to
other actors that I really got a sense
of it with that film specifically I knew
that I had to do some serious prep and
the great thing was that James Marshall
director allowed us the time I had about
8 weeks I worked with the dancer because
I needed someone to go through the
physical side of things with me and when
you're when you're making a film the
director is you know is doing locations
casting it has got so much going on
working on the script that actually to
have a really intricate relationship
with something like movement you kind of
have to go out on your own
and I asked if I could work with a
movement specialist and so I met this
one called Alexandra Reynolds who'd
worked on World War Z all the zombies on
that she talks about the body in kind of
sculptural terms so she said imagine
mercury in your pelvis and imagine
trying to keep that flat and try and so
we said this workshop session and I'd
never worked like that and found it kind
of riveting we then spent about eight
weeks going to and motor neuron disease
clinic and meeting patients and doctors
and really took that all the information
that we were given there and then tried
to relate it to Stevens decline looked
at photos of Steven took photos of
Steven to the doctors who would then see
what his decline may have been and then
we started prepping
trying to find that in my body and it
was literally as sort of mathematical
because with motor neuron disease ii
something stops working it never works
again so there had to be an accuracy to
that and I sort of charted it all out
and I've never done that quite as um as
rigorously of specific body parts and
when they stopped working on whether
they had up a neuron or lower neuron and
and I tried to do all that work in
advance so that when it actually came to
filming firstly you could jump in
between the different time frames having
hopefully done all that homework so when
it came to working with Felicity you
just you weren't even thinking about it
and you were just able to respond to
whatever she was she was giving but
within the confines of what the
restrictions of the disease and that
makes sense so the first day of filming
of theory of everything the morning was
Steven and able-bodied and then um at
lunchtime was I was playing in one two
walking sticks and then in the afternoon
in the in the first chair and then later
on evening in the last chair and and and
I was totally terrifying become but at
the same point the great thing about it
I could quite often find with filming
you know it's actually quite good to
jump in with a difficult scene I'm
following up from that like how was your
prepped for the Danish girl how you got
into the the mindset of your character
and how you were able to execute it so
so wonderfully was really interesting
with the Danish girl because I've been
cast in it or offered the film and we
were making them as a Rob which was
about four years ago what was
interesting is it sits with you you read
a script and you have a that that story
sits with you and you start doing sort
of research not knowing whether the
films going to happen
I was then lucky enough to work with
lana wachowski and i spoke to her about
lily and Gerda's story and she was I
mean she spoke so passionately about it
and she really pointed me in the right
direction as to where to start reading
and educating myself on trans issues and
trans stories and the other great thing
about our job is you get to meet amazing
people and I got to meet trans women and
their partners and
and men all around the world of
different generations so I started
really with what trying to take water
here contemporary trans experience and
then place that within the context of
Lily's story at a time in which there
were no predecessors there was no
language there was no community and
really try and work out what her
emotional story may have been and it was
it was complicated by the fact that our
films based on a fictionalized version
of their story so you're already quite
far from the truth and yet there are
these amazing paintings that Gerda did
of Lily said those were a great resource
it was about trying to take really as
much research from the period meeting
women living now and then try to find
elements of that in yourself in terms of
how you've started and where you are now
like what are some of the like
hard-hitting truths that you've learnt
about since being in the industry I've
been really lucky um and yet still it
does feel like it's really hard it's
what we are in a trade in which so many
people in the world want to do it it's
something that we everyone who does it
is passionate about and and as a
consequence there are there are there
are complications and and the reality is
a sort of it's very difficult to take
charge of your life because you don't
have control like you really don't I've
seen it with you know elder actors who
we think of as sort of icons and they
are still on a list of actors and you
know they so and so will get the part
for that for that moment and then
someone else who's down here will do a
film that suddenly raised it and then
you sort of slip down and you're you are
on a list for your entire life and
you're a commodity in some ways and if
you have a moment of success then that's
great but you also know that it's just a
matter of time until all sort of you
know has done so there's that but also
you become great friends with actors
because those people are going through
the specifics of what you're going
through and it's great to be able to
share that with people but there's also
this sort of oddness that is you're
going up against your best mate for jobs
and
and frequently losing and then man sort
of dealing with one sense of sort of
competition it's also amazing use it of
you today that's amount of times in my
life I've gone damn it bastard didn't
get it but at least someone I love got
it how do you keep that truth of the
project that you want to do especially
now at a time where you can be able to
hopefully have a wider choice it could
be like this one or that one no the
first thing is that is the point of
choice and kind of going back to what we
said before about having no control is
that the notion that you have choice is
an actor is pretty rare and even if as I
was saying with those elder
extraordinary iconic actors there's
probably someone who's been offered it
before that other actor in it you know
and there's it and so choice is an
interesting one and choice is not
something that I've really had until
recently it's change shifted slightly
but theory of everything I was sent a
script for I was so moved by it as I'd
love to meet for this and you were made
aware that there are five other people
that have been offered it because you're
not a financeable thingy or or and you
go in and you fight basically the answer
to your question is it's about an
instinct and it comes from reading a
script that first time through and and
you feel something or you don't
that word is saying that your mind
thrown around a lot of people go trust
your instincts and you're going hey how
do I know my instinct is like why
because the second you have an instinct
you question it how do you tell the
difference between what you feel is is
good in your acting what you feel in
terms of like emotional reasoning and
what an audience feel is good very
interesting question and and the answer
is you always disappoint yourself as an
actor ones notion of it of what a
character is versus what ends up being
on screen is is never um it never makes
you content because you or only see your
flaws but with that there is a did a
play about Mark Rothko
and and his assistant at that time wrote
this this little thing which it was
about being a pictorial artist but he
said being an artist is not about talent
and all that it's about the aspiration
for perfection with the acknowledgement
that you'll never attain it so like it's
kind of learning to enjoy the process of
aspiring for a perfection that you won't
ever get and so with theatre for example
people often going me how can you do it
like the nine months how can you do the
same thing you go because you never get
one line right let alone a whole
playwright you also you don't have
enough distance so when I watch a film I
always say to a director I would love to
see it but I I need to see it once in
the morning by myself
then go away for lunch then come back
and watch it again and then see you
afterwards to sort of discuss it because
the first time you see it or you can see
is the glaring flaws and and in your
work and and actually you have no
objectivity you can't see the bigger
picture
which is always interesting with films
because you prepare it in that vacuum
you prepare your own character and you
sort of forget it is actually you're
sort of young part of an ensemble and
and and I really do find as much as
hideous as it is watching myself
sometimes I find early on an issue or
then go come on I just watch that back
with you and they go here and you go oh
god okay totally get it but let me go
and sort that out because again what you
feel you're doing versus what you're
what's coming across is I'm different I
know a lot of actors say they don't
watch play that but I'm probably not one
of those it's about trying to find a
balance between and that fresh and like
in the moment just being in the moment
and the technical-scientific
to where your body is shifting and how
the camera and the cinematographer is
like the voice everything the light
everything so you have to also I'm
learning to balance that and not to be
afraid of that because for me if I could
I'll just be like just stick the camera
on and I'll just do what I have to do
hopefully but you have to appreciate and
respect that there's a technical aspect
to it exactly what you said like the
mixture you know the amazing thing about
filming itself is it's this combination
kind of science and art in some ways
you've got these cameras and
extraordinary technical facilities and
then you've got this animus and
restrictions and the limitations as to
where you can move what you can do
versus you wanting to be completely free
thank you very much thank you really
really enjoyed that what's your top tip
for learning lines for me there is none
normally involved walking around a patch
of grass in a circle at about 5:00 in
the morning for a long time even if
you're under pressure really since the
small signals actors will send to you
about how they want to be directed each
actor absolutely has to be handled in a
different way in order to make the whole
ensemble work
you